thank you so much and thank you so much
to the organizing committee for putting
so much thought into making this safe so
space and inclusive I really really
appreciate all of that I wrote in the
abstract the description for this talk
that it was going to be a whirlwind tour
and we're starting a little bit late and
I have a hundred slides so it is gonna
be so freaking fast
it's a Saturday morning at this time I
would be starting my second lap of
Catford park run and it's gonna feel
that way by the earth know it thank you
so much for being here thank you so much
for being here on the Saturday morning
and I am so so delighted to tell you a
little bit about this project that's
called the cheering way the cheering way
is a book it's a community it is a
global collaboration and it is a bonkers
amount of work and I always find it sad
when I put my acknowledgement slides at
the very end and then I sort of run out
of time and go oh yeah and also people
did work so I want to take a moment and
say thank you so much - Rachel Becky
Louise Sarah Patricia James rosianna
Katherine Alex Martin all of the binder
team from project Jupiter and all of our
contributors and I hope that this slide
will go out of date I am very excited
that every time I give this talk this
slide is out of dates because we have
new contributors who were acknowledging
in our readme so thank you to them let
me just tell you a little bit about
myself this is me using docker on my
Windows laptop for the first time and I
am like wildly joyful about being in
this space where someone has helped me
figure this out and I'm currently a
research fellow at the Alan Turing
institutes my sort of origin story for
caring about reproducibility is that
during my PhD at UC Berkeley in
neuroscience I was very very good in the
way that most PhD students are at coming
up with null results I was very very
strong at finding things that were not
statistically significant but I had a
side thing of being particularly good at
finding results that were in the
opposite direction of published results
so they were significant
but not what people are expecting and
that really sort of led me to realize
that there is a huge huge amount of bias
in the published literature and this
file drawer effect this feeling of that
the result is not what you were
expecting the result is going to be
difficult to publish in the current
environment so I'm just gonna quietly
put it in my file drawer and move on to
a new study is one of my like driving
reasons for caring about this because it
is such a waste of so many people's time
every time you graduate students arrive
and think they have a cool new idea and
there's a bunch of seniors academics
saying no try to doesn't work but you
have no way of knowing that so that's
why I care about reproducibility but I
also I think it's really important to
have a slide on here to point out that
it's not just wasting people's time
there are also really really big effects
of errors in the academic literature so
this is a screen grab of an Excel
spreadsheet it has some numbers in there
it has some countries in the first
column and if you can see closely in
column L only some of the cells are
highlighted and this is a paper that was
published by economist Reinhart and
Rogoff two economists and it has been
used the paper has been used to justify
austerity in multiple countries
including the UK and I could probably
stand here and use the entire rest of my
time to tell you how harmful austerity
measures have been particularly for the
most vulnerable people in this country
and the only reason why we know that
this paper has an error is because
Thomas in London who is now a faculty
member at Stanford when he was a PhD
student in economics he had to as part
of his coursework reproduced the
findings from the published from a
published paper he chose Reinhart and
rogoff's paper he got in touch with them
he asked for their data and he was the
one who realized that when they had
calculated the values that they were
publishing they had just missed out
these last five countries when you do
actually reanalyze the data correctly
you get a qualitatively different
results and so one of my biggest
take-home messages if I have a blue
sliders because I want you to remember
it
is that the technological parts of
reproducibility and I am gonna talk a
little bit about some infrastructure
work they are not the hard parts the
hard parts are the human people involved
the incentive structures that make it
very difficult to want to show that you
have made a mistake so kudos to Reinhart
and Rogoff for sharing their data with
that PhD student when he asked but not
kudos to them for not retracting the
paper when he found that there was a
mistake this slide is to tell you what I
mean by reproducibility and it's very
important to me that I do not care what
you call these concepts I have no desire
to have any sort of armwrestling
over the specific definitions I just
want you to know what I am talking about
when I refer to these different words
and particularly reproducible because
that's the point of my talk and when I
use the word reproducible I mean that if
I have the exact same data that you have
and I follow the exact same analysis
that the exact same data wrangling the
exact same analysis the exact same data
cleaning at the very end I can get the
same results as you now I'm very
interested in whether you if you run
that same pipeline on a different data
set whether you get the same results I
would call that a replicated finding and
I'm also very interested in whether if
you write your code in Python versus
write your code in Arvest is do your
anova by hand whether you get the same
results and I would call that a robust
finding it doesn't you're not sort of
specific about the quirks of the way
that that code has been written and then
I think that you need both of those
things together to make a generalizable
finding it is not generalized it does
not actually extend to all of the people
but it is at least a step towards saying
it's not something specific about this
data set and it's not something specific
about my particular version of the code
that allows us to be able to stand on
the shoulders of giants and do really
important work so I've already sort of
hinted that there's lots and lots of
barriers to reproducible research I
think probably my favorites on this
slide is the plead the fifth which comes
from reading too many american crime
novels as a teenager
it's basically saying that why would
people want to give evidence against
themselves we know that there are
mistakes in the published literature why
would anybody put their head up above
the parapet and say I made a mistake I
would love as I said in one of the
previous slides to build a world where
it's okay to be human we know that there
are mistakes we know that everybody
makes mistakes
I don't think fraud is our biggest
problem in this area I think it's just
the fact that we don't build incentive
structures to actually check the other
ones that I want to just sort of high
that put pullouts is this one about the
fact that people think that reproducible
research takes time and I think it only
does if you're thinking in a very short
few of success so I actually think that
if you automate things and if you can
make things run from beginning to end
over and over you can actually be much
much more successful in the long run it
just takes a bit of time to learn some
extra skills let me give you a couple of
slides about the turing institute this
is this is not alan turing this is a
very delightful benedict cumberbatch
this is a picture of Alan Turing who
became icon of the 20th century a couple
of months ago who was voted by the UK
public and this is a slide that
basically just tells you to all go to
Bletchley Park if you're ever able to it
is a ridiculously delightful way to
spend a day and it's where I'll ensuring
did an awful lot of the work that he is
now known but in his time was not known
for breaking the Enigma codes to help in
the effort for the Allied forces during
World War two the turing institute is
one-third funded by government it's
one-third funded by our partner
universities and it's one-third funded
by the institute's partners and
collaborators and I'm really really
proud to work in a place that is
specifically focused on
interdisciplinarity and bringing people
together and ideally translating some of
this somewhat sometimes esoteric work in
research in academic research into the
real world through our partner
institutions
the Institute has some challenges I
think it's pretty exciting to try and
work in a place that's trying to
revolutionize healthcare supercharged
research in the sciences and humanities
or maybe shine a light on the economy
and I really really love the fact that
we are focused on the fact that we need
core capabilities in order to deliver on
those applied challenges Martin o Reilly
is my sort of co-creator of this work
and he came up with our tagline which is
make reproducible research too easy not
to do it is such a wild moonshots but um
we're probably never going to actually
achieve it but it's really really good
to try and to give him a shout out for
the fact that I get very frustrated
about the lack of reproducibility and I
get quite angry towards sort of three
o'clock in the afternoon and so he is
the person who comes along holds my hand
and is like do you need a biscuit
I do need a biscuit thanks very much
much and thank you for listening to me
and he is also the person that gave me
this piece of sort of support that
sounds on the face of it kind of
negative there if the UK's National
Institute for data science and
artificial intelligence can't
incentivize reproducible research no way
I can and that's kind of that's kind of
a bummer but I find that quite exciting
I find it sort of I feel like I'm in the
right place to be bringing people
together who care about these sorts of
problems so we created a project called
the cheering way and the cheering way is
a jupiter book this is a screen grab of
the jupiter book maybe I'll take a
moment just to stop and tell you that
down at the bottom here there's a DOI
link and that means that all of the
slides are available so if you can't
read the stuff on the slides that's okay
I'm going super super fast on here but
you can download all of those there
cc-by which means that you are only able
to use them reuse them remix them just
keep the attribution at the very
beginning and if you'd like contribute
any changes back so the cheering way is
a lightly opinionated guide -
reproducible data science and our goal
is to make sure that PhD students
postdocs pas and funding teams know
which parts of the responsibility of
reproducibility they can effect
and I think that we're trying to focus
on the fact that reproducible research
requires additional skills those are the
things that we're trying to help people
learn and we're trying to get over that
initial time investment and I am also
spending a lot of time telling people
that this is really important with the
goal of changing some of the hiring
structure in academia to recognize that
for example working on open-source
projects and contributing code to make
it easier for other people to be able to
run their experiments is a really
valuable contribution and you should be
able to get a job to do that there's a
chapter where we talk about the fare
principles farads and for findable
accessible interoperable and reusable it
was designed for data it is there's
currently a working group from the force
community thinking about how you can
apply those principles to software and
whether you can apply them to other
types of outputs and one of my greatest
inspirations was a conversation with
Catherine Lawrence who is a senior
program manager at the churring
Institute so she's not an academic but
she wrangles academics and in her
interview to become a senior program
manager she gave this answer it is like
the most delightful thing when she told
me about it that she had said that all
of the processes that the churring
Institute business team should be
working on should be findable so for
example they should be on our intranet
and people should be able to locate them
easily accessible we should be centering
equality diversity and inclusion in
every consideration that we have
interoperable about across programs and
projects so the health program may not
have exactly the same needs as the the
theta centric engineering program for
example but they will have some
commonalities and if we can keep our
processes interoperable then we share
and we grow together and they should be
reusable and she was particularly
thinking about the bus or the truck
factor so that when people leave if you
don't lose knowledge along with them I
know you know or most of you know about
the importance of testing I it is one of
my big pushes because I don't think very
much academic
code is actually tested but I do think
that a lot of academics are doing tests
as they do their work I think we call
them sanity checks I think we plot
graphs to look at the distributions I
think people are testing I just don't
think that they know the programmatic
ways to do that work automatically so
here's a little gift I'm just going to
break it down in the next couple of
slides I've added a son because I think
it's not super super clear that this
that this is the daytime but is when
it's the daytime when it's morning if
you put this little piece of Python code
in here and you get the time of day and
it gives you the answer morning and you
assert that morning and morning are
equal then your tests will pass at
nighttime when you get the time of day
and it says night time when you assert
that night time and morning are equal
your tests will fail it's an extremely
simple piece of code but it's really
really valuable for continuing to check
what you're doing and whether it's still
doing what you think it's doing it being
your code your analysis your work
whatever you want to call it and when
this shouts out Louise who's a research
engineer and data scientist who works on
the team and her big piece of advice is
add a test before you change anything
and particularly add a test if you're
going to clean up your code before you
send it to us to see if we can reproduce
your analyses the hardest thing that we
have found is people sending us better
versions of their code which are
probably objectively better in fact they
can tell you that they are the models
fits better they give better answers but
they are not reproducible and I want to
spend a couple of slides on continuous
analysis so continuous analysis is
inspired by continuous integration which
again I expect a lot of you in the room
will already know and but it fits really
really well with the scientific method
as we are taught the scientific method
is not is supposed to be not the way
that the scientific method is actually
instantiated in the way that we do our
work at the moment because that's got
like a whole bunch of problems but if
you plan and design your experiment then
you write those steps down in code then
you pushed it to version control and run
the analyses
and I want to highlight here that if you
are able to make your code if you're
able to put your code up on a public
server and more importantly if you're
able to put your data up on a public
server then there's lots of tools that
you can use to do that but you don't
need to make your data public in order
to follow the process of continuous
integration the important part is that
all of the steps are run every time you
make a difference and then you test to
see what's changed and this is a project
this is one of our champions projects
and I've unfortunately had to cut a lot
of the details because I'm going super
super fast
anyway but it runs on Travis and at the
very end you get the beautiful beautiful
green text that says the command PI test
- be exited with zero and you get mad
excited about live because it feels so
good to be validated in a job where no
one validates you for most of the time
just to reiterate I am recommending to
researchers that they run the analyses
from start to finish as they work that
many times the test will fail and that's
exactly what you expect you are building
the work that is exactly what you what
you design you know that you're making
of improvements as you go along but
sometimes tests will fail unexpectedly
and continuous integration continuous
analysis makes you be really explicit
about whether you think you should be
getting a different result or not so the
big example that I think is really
really motivating for people who are
writing academic papers is that you work
for about six months on figure one you
show it to your collaborators they say
that's really good
then you go away and you work for three
months on figure two then you go and
work for another couple of months on
figure three and what I have experienced
and what I have witnessed is that often
times by the time you're running your
code for figure three you are no longer
getting the same output for figure one
or for Table one and so what I'm
advocating for is that you run things
all the way through all the time it's
fine to update the tests I know that
sacrilege if you're working in
production type environments but in this
in this case it's fine and in fact it's
really really positive to be checking
and being X
it's every time there's parts of this
paragraph here that says all of this is
sometimes easier said than done
and that is like too freaking true man
and so I want to shout out Becky
Arnold but he doesn't like having her
pictures sort of flown around on the
Internet's everywhere and by a sort of
somewhat happy coincidence this is what
she looks like when she joins a zoom
call there's something very strange
about the way that her laptop interacts
with the software and so this is Becky
she is back working on her PhD in
astrophysics she did a massive amounts
of work writing the core chapters of the
cheering way as they exist at the moment
and it was her insight that pointed out
the fact that you need to know so many
things before you can actually get to
continuous integration and so at the
beginning of our chapter we have some
prerequisites and we recommend reading
certain chapters before you get there
and I have a couple of slides here on
version control gits is different to get
hub get is the vision is the software
that's actually doing the version
control github is the collaborating part
and we have two different chapters in
the Turing way that helps people
understand those differences and this is
probably one of my favorite pictures of
2080 and this is Dan Gale and I had been
helping him understand the collaboration
pathway of doing a pull request on
github and he went away and he drew this
up and I just loved his smile for this
feeling of like oh my god I finally got
fades and he was at a summer school that
I teach out it's called neuro Academy so
it's for neuroscientists learning data
science skills and one of the
participants there and I can't remember
who it was it came up in conversation so
I'm crediting every one of the PhD
students and postdocs who were there
that every hackathon should have a gong
that you can ring when you complete your
first pull request it is so hard to do
that first pull request and we as a
community who are comfortable with doing
pull requests make it really difficult
for people to contribute if we forget
that so my task for all of you if you
know how to do a pull request my ask is
that you find five people before the end
of this
and you help them do their first pull
request because if we can get people on
version control systems almost
everything else can flow quite easily
from there but this barrier is huge and
it it is beneficial to us to recognize
how important it is to emphasize them
we've also done within the the cheering
way we've done some workshops and
trainings which fits in obviously with
that very heavy point that I made
earlier I do not have time to talk you
through all of them we went up to
Manchester and we took a photo with our
ensuring statue up there we had some
lovely vegan cake we were focusing on
binder which is going to come up in a
couple of slides time and we also want
to shout out the carpentry is because
they were doing they we use their own
post-its method of putting a little
yellow post-it up if everything's going
well and a red or a pink post-it up if
you have any questions and so in the
bottom right corner there you've got
anna chris tolly who's a member of the
team being extremely excited that she
was buying building her binder hub in
sheffield and rosie Hickman who's the
data librarian at Sheffield who works on
weights on the Turing way projects she
was really integral as well as other
members of the team in focusing on the
fact that if you run events when you're
only preaching to the choir you're
missing the potential and we really need
to show researchers the selfish reasons
to follow our recommendations so arguing
for a moral goods will only get you so
far
we ran a couple of events called book
dashes a book sprint is something like
where you get together for a week or
three days to write a book together a
book dash is a one-day event that I made
up it's pretty intense and we've run -
in Manchester in London and it was
absolutely magical you can read a little
bit more about them in those reports I
want to thank all of our participants
for coming along having dinner with us
the night before and then working their
tiny socks off from 9:00 a.m. until 5:00
p.m. on contributing all of their
knowledge into the cheering way I told
you that I would tell you about binder
finder is a project that is part of
project Jupiter and this is a wonderful
wonderful sketch that I've taken from
Juliet who shared it on Twitter
Jana's written a paper based on her
experiments and she
anyone to be able to reproduce check and
improve what she's done
so she describes the experiments as a
notebook oh and it's a highlight here
that it doesn't have to be a notebook it
can be any sort of script that runs in
Jupiter lab or it can be our and run in
our studio and she publishes them on a
publicly hosted repository and she makes
that repository binder ready by
describing the software required to run
the notebook so she has the
configuration the notebook and some
resources and then down at this very
little bottom part here there's a little
there's a little step which I'm going to
explain to you and then once you run
that little step in the background the
whole world is able in their browser
without having to install anything to
read and what she's done so that step
right there is building a binder hub and
running repeater docker so binder hub is
the software and the infrastructure and
the processes that coordinate cloud
computing resources with kubernetes make
it easy for users to access their and
interact with the code using a Jupiter
hub and sets up the environments and
brings in the files that you need from a
github repository and Sara Gibson who's
a research engineer and data scientist
at the churring Institute's she told me
that it took a long while to feel like
she knew enough to contribute to binder
but the team are always so excited to
have my inputs and it's really
motivating to be part of such a
welcoming community and when she joined
the cheering way team this is the first
job out of out of her PhD in
astrophysics and she had never
contributed to an open-source project
she is now a maintainer for binder
she is doing the most cool and amazing
work and I am so delighted that the
binder team were so welcoming and so
supportive to have her come in to join
them now this is me eating nachos in
Portland Oregon and and one of the
things that I personally love about
binder as someone who mostly just sits
in meetings and like doesn't really
reply to emails is that I can check my
collaborators and the students that I
work with I can check their analyses on
my phone I don't have to install things
I don't have to have a couple of hours
or three hours where I get to sit at my
desk and really work on code
can review their code and run it and
suggest changes from wherever I am very
very easily and this is one of the
aspects where I really want to share
this responsibility for reproducibility
with principal investigators faculty
with your managers with anybody else who
should care about putting this work out
in a reasonable and sort of reliable way
the reason that I love binder is it
feels so fun to be able to run analyses
in the in the browser it feels really
good to be able to sort of sit and see
things and play with them and check
other people's work but it also requires
you to be using version control and
capturing your computational environment
so there's specific versions of the
libraries that you're using and it does
a new build for every change that you
make so it's actually in the background
really really encouraging people to use
all of these best practices my binder is
a public hosted instance of binder hub
and there's Google Cloud and OVH have an
instance and so there's a federation and
you'll get pings you'll see the famous
binder spinner as it's building the work
for you and I want to just show you a
little example of the fact that you can
and zoom through the the answer to the
question how much does this cost energy
per two notebook you can see the very
very sharp line in December on there was
when the binder team went to Europe's
and ran a GPU for the day so it costs a
lot of money and what we are doing at
the churring Institute's is thinking
about building and trying to incentivize
others to build their own binder hubs
because you might want to have more
computational power than the public
vision gives you because if you had if
they gave you all the most powerful
machines you'd be spending an awful lot
of project Jupiters money and you may
also want to have a Yui you may want to
limit who is able to see the code and
see the data as you're working and so
here's here's one that Sarah built
it has a smaller binder logo and as a
larger Alan Turing Institute's name and
Alayna Katinka is one of our
reproducible research champions she has
a deep learning model that looks at um
how rumors are classified in social
media and this data is quite large data
and it's a big deep learning model and
so it won't run on the public find a hub
but it will run
doot-doot-doot these are the results i
know you can't see them but i'm telling
you and you can look at the slides later
that you can get those results on our
instance of the binder hub because we
give it a little bit extra power behind
it now I've left this slide in here not
to make a lean Alena feel bad about the
fact that you get different answers on
running running your analyses on
different systems but to highlight the
point that if we do not give people the
ability to check their work and the
ability to run their analyses on
different systems then they will be in
the same position as Alena and say I
only have access to one system I have no
idea that I will get different results
on different systems Garrett has a
different example I'm gonna go mega fast
through this one but I put it in here
because I want I want you to go to this
clever CSV demo this one does run on the
public binder hub you can go and access
it you can click on this little launch
binder button it will take you up to a
fantastic notebook that talks you
through reading in some IMDB movie data
and then finding some errors in reading
in CSV files he has a great question of
why on earth the CSV files so freaking
hard man and his quote is that the fun
part of data science is in the modeling
and being able to read in information
from a CSV file should not be although
probably there's lots of people in the
room who realized that it is the hardest
part of our day I asked him when I was
preparing these slides I wants to make
sure that I could talk about his work
appropriately and I said where's the
where's the AI in this work and he was
like no no there is no AI i sat there
last
and I classified lots and lots of errors
and lots and lots of CSV files and I I
left that in there because it kind of
made me smile and it made me recognize
that so much of the work that we call
and we sell as artificial intelligence
is actually just reading in CSV files in
a reliable and responsible way and well
when you go and I really want you to go
to this demo you will be able to click
on the repository that actually wrote
the paper this is what it looks like the
paper is up on archive and there is a
make file in there so his whole paper is
reproducible from beginning to end and
he then wrote for as a chapter about
make because he wanted everyone to know
about this so the reason that we have
these case studies is to show that it
can be done is to provide templates and
starting points for all of the people
that are coming along to our community
and want to do their work in a more
reproducible way and to inspire them to
show to sort of think about ways that
they can share their knowledge and share
the work that they're doing I said at
the very beginning that the cheering way
is a global collaboration and this is a
quote from Patricia who really worked as
a sort of community manager for the
first six months of the project what
sets the Turing way apart is how we're
writing the book there's a focus on
community a commitment to transparency
and working open right from the very
beginning we follow the Mozilla open
leadership principles of making the work
accessible and clear making it easy to
adapt reproduce and spread and building
shared ownership and agency to make the
work inviting and sustainable for all
from the very beginning so I showed you
these contributors I'm gonna skip a
little bit over all of the various
different ways that people can
contribute but I really really really
want to encourage you to go and check
out the emoji key from the all
contributors project they have a little
box that will add people so that you are
no longer just counting the number of
permits that people have made you're
counting whether they've given talks
about it whether they've written
tutorials whether they've shared ideas
done event organizing the many many ways
that we all know contribute to the
health of a community Rachel who worked
on the project did a lot of really
really great and deep thinking about
personas and pathways so how do we
identify people to come in and work on
the project at the moment it's still a
work in progress because we only have
academic examples on her so Sam Alex
Amaal and Nora all within the university
ecosystems and I would really really
love to have that broaden out to members
of the business team at the cheering for
example but also people like a lot of
you so how you are interested in
contributing to the Turing way how these
sorts of tools can be valuable to you
and at our book events we had some
incredible artwork created by Matt from
scribe area and I think this is my
favorite one of the various ways in
which we want to support all of the
people around us we got a funding
extension booyah and this is now my
favorite image I am a meme because
everything you say I say that could be a
chapter in the cheering way we're
expanding the scope to include ethics
model selection project management
collaborative working how do you
collaborate is really freaking hard and
a lot of researchers don't know how to
do it and we are recruiting for a full
time community manager we want
contributions from inside of the
cheering but we also want them from
everybody else these are our metrics of
success and I want to highlight for you
the 50 first pull request we want to
have 50 people feel safe and feel
welcome to do that first scary pull
request into our project repository and
we want 20 people to come to the
cheering way community realize that a
contribution could be made elsewhere and
make that contribution so that they go
and join other open source project
communities thank you to the current and
the future contributors and thank you
all so much for listening
[Applause]